we're here today to talk to you all
about class participation class
participation is one of the most
important ways that you can engage with
the GSB and enhance your own learning
but it can be hard if at the end of this
talk you're going to have several
effective tips to learn to participate
in an effective manner but first let's
take a dive into a typical GSD classroom
shimano I hope you guys read the case in
the 1980's Shimano introduced a
phenomenal drivetrain that you'd
evolutionized the biking industry who
can tell me what was the competitive
advantage that Shimano pursued back then
don't make me cold call Kathleen I'm not
a hundred percent sure but I think you
might have been going for perceived
quali I disagree
I'm not an expert by all means and
drivetrain I really think it's welcome
there Shimano pursues a perceived
quality competitive advantage they do
this in several ways first the great
drivetrain really provides superior
riding experience for end users they
also do marketing in sponsorships to
reforge the perception of quality
quality job of users in terms of costs
they nucleus coach for the skills that
allow them for increasing willingness to
paint without a pony current decrease in
price and cause how many of you have
been in classes where comments like the
ones made by 70 and Kathleen added zero
value to come to the conversation
I know I've been there and you just want
to choke those people but it's comments
like the one made by Leo that actually
add value to the conversation and move
it forward so we're here today to talk
to you about class participation why
it's important why it's hard and how to
do it effectively so why it's important
well for one it enhances learning each
one of you has a unique experience and
we're here to learn from each other the
case method which a lot of the classes
of the GSP depend on depend on
collaboration between the professor and
the students we want to hear what you
have to say so by sharing your
experience
you're not only enhancing your learning
experience you're enhancing the learning
experience of everyone and the class -
great I know you all want to get good
grades if you don't know already
participation will account for a large
portion of your grade at the GSB and if
you're one of those people that are
going for the RJ Miller status trust me
you're going to need those points and if
you are like me you're going for the
friends of RJ Miller status then you
also need those points and lastly build
reputation class participation will be
for many of you the first time your
classmates will hear your voice so try
to build reputation for yourself from
the start through class participation
so we know the class participation is
important but it's also really hard or
dissipated in class can cause a lot of
anxiety for a host of different reasons
there's cultural elements that play
diverse backgrounds or limited
experience and the social factor of
talking in a large group cultural
differences can be really challenging at
the GSB if you come you're coming to a
new country you're maybe speaking a
language that isn't your first language
in some cultures you have you should
really defer to the position the person
of authority or it's really not
commonplace to dissent publicly and
openly but we want to remind you that
the majority of the GEOSS the GSB
students come from all over the world
40% of students are international and we
have representation from 53 different
countries so you're not alone how you
feel there's somebody else in the room
who feels the same way another concern
often comes with your background I'm
just out of undergrad I've only worked a
year or two I don't really know anything
or I never worked in finance how can I
participate in the finance class well
actually asking questions is one of the
best ways to participate and what you
bring your background and your
experience is really valuable in the
classroom and just a reminder there's
all of us at the GSB come from lots of
different industries and even
traditional backgrounds of consulting
finance investing is only 40 percent of
the class the rest of the class has
experience in manufacturing clean tech
government education all of these things
are super valuable to the collaborative
learning environment finally the social
impact this is um tricky because it's
hard to speak in a room full of people
and I mean we've talked about how people
are more afraid of dying or people are
more afraid of public speaking than they
are of dying but leo is here to help you
address this kind of issue and learn to
participate effectively in the classroom
you all know that a class participation
really is important you also know that
brings a lot of a lot of risks and
excited whether it related to it what
you want to share with you today is a
simple framework that will help you
succeed in a classroom they're based on
preparation presence and power
let's begin by preparation preparation
is the best way to reduce all the
excitement it may have before persuading
class the first tip is quite obvious
just read the case know your facts and
positions before you come to class it's
also great when we all have such a
diverse experience so it would be great
if if have military experience wearing
social impact experience in Africa
commercial banking bring them to the
cave discussion bring your home
experience for the benefit of the whole
class and finally the first two are if
you're serious you are sure about
sharing these in a group like this have
a small group of lessons a small study
group and share your ideas with them
before speaking in a in the whole class
now we're prepared it's time to go to
the classroom which is just like this
and it is true you are being evaluated
100% of the time not only by the
professor's but also by all of ourselves
the first thing that it should be
concerned with is your own presence how
are you how are you being perceived by
your classmates how's your posture are
you keeping eye contact with everyone or
not
and sorry lastly it's also important to
be an active listener why is this
important you don't want to make a
comment that has nothing to do with
what's being discussed or stopped in a
moment like I just did and just don't
know what to say finally you have
preparations you have a great present in
class now it's your turn you are the one
who have the power to move the
conversation forward to really move the
middle bring your ideas in a sexy way
and share your own sites with the whole
group it's okay not to agree it's okay
to make questions they actually helped a
lot that so other students can see the
same subject in a totally different way
and better understand the whole material
being stressed
participation is hard Kathleen has
shared some reasons why we come from
different backgrounds to come from
different work experiences and we've got
thrown into a room like this the social
pressure is high it's hard but it is not
impossible
léo share with us the three P's
preparation presence and power we're now
going to pass out a handout that shares
some content delivery tips for your
class participation as you embark today
on your GSB journey and go to your first
classes and participate with the case
method we want you to keep a few more
things in mind first keep a broad
perspective it's one Commons in one
class in one class session in one
quarter you don't need to be perfect if
you say something that you're not happy
with trust me you'll have many more
opportunities also the skill set is not
just applicable in the case method
environment here at the GSB learning how
to participate in large group settings
will be applicable to you as you leave
the GSB and employees on your career
also learn to laugh trust me there will
be a time when you forget the case
protagonist name or there will be time
the class will start laughing like in my
experience when you say and open your
comment for the third time with when I
was working at the sausage factory
section one knows so keep a smile on
your face and realize it's not the end
of the world and finally be patient you
don't enter the GSB and you're not going
to be perfect at your first day in your
classes on class participation don't
hold yourself to that standard because
we're not holding you to that standard
Derrick Bolton did not admit you to the
GSB because you were a perfect class
participator from day one he admitted
you because you are unique because you
have a unique perspective because you
come from unique backgrounds with
diverse experiences and because
you have something to say please bring
that to the classroom we ask you today
to bring your whole self to the
classroom to participate and commit to
raising your hand in class in fact we're
going to give you an opportunity to
start today as we now open it up for
questions in your example
are you kind of rising the perfect comet
in a way that may be sometimes saying
the wrong thing or saying an awkward
idea helps the class get to ultimately
where everyone's to be as opposed to
just so many reason I have perfectly
outlined in what they wrote in the case
how it fits into learning
we're not saying you have to be perfect
that's not exactly what we're trying to
say and hopefully didn't come across
that way what we are saying is we want
to alleviate the stress and anxiety of
you to actually raise your hand so if
you go through the preparation and think
about how you come across in class with
the presence and know that you do have
the power to move the needle it can help
you be in a place that you're willing to
raise your hand we I think all of us
would agree that there are comments
there sometimes half-formed
that aren't maybe correct that really do
help move the needle and move a
conversation forward and we encourage
those as well we just want to help give
you tips that will help alleviate any
stress or anxiety to encourage you to
raise your hand and participate in class